let's talk about this breaking news man
this is huge the election is not over
from al jazeera trump campaign
challenges over 100 000 votes in georgia
new lawsuit is latest in long line of
trump challenges
to u.s election results most of which
have been thrown out
president trump's campaign filed another
lawsuit seeking over to overturn
the united states election results the
campaign announced friday this time
contesting more than 100
000 votes in the state of georgia the
new lawsuit filed by the trump campaign
and georgia's republican party
alleges that massive irregularities
mistakes and potential fraud took place
in the state
now you know what i really really love
about this latest lawsuit
when the republican party is in it with
trump and they're saying yes
look at all these problems and then when
giuliani drops an actual video and
there's a lawyer an attorney
saying look at this video of people
pulling ballot boxes out from under a
table
after they told everyone to leave and
then counting tens of thousands of votes
at into one into one am with no
observers present
george's gop secretary of state says he
has already investigated
bombshell video rudy giuliani claims
proof voting fraud and says it shows
nothing out of the ordinary you mean you
mean to tell me
that once everyone leaves they
immediately scuttle over and pull box
out from under tables and then start
counting them
up until 1 a.m and that's normal i want
to know what's ordinary
yeah in the first place but giuliani is
calling this the smoking gun
and the bank heist video i mean you
could make a lot of interpretations but
i hope the person in the video
is set to testify i hope she's under
oath and i hope we find out what
happened with that usb
that was clutched and so well that's not
that's not in the story but people have
been posting a video
that shows a woman with blonde braids
they say is the same person
i'll be very careful because i don't
know what this video is but you see this
woman
she's sitting talking to someone and
then she palms a usb stick
and then clutches it and the camera's
like zoomed in and she stands up and
then like slides it in her pocket
there are other videos of people doing
this there's a
for what reason are they putting usb
sticks into
like voting terminals at these polling
locations and then pocketing them and
walking out
because you'd think if it was something
routine they'd walk right up and pull
the stick and put it in there and talk
to people and then
take it out look at it and you know put
it away but they're like palming it like
trying to hide it
so i don't know who that lady is in that
video i can only assume they're saying
it's the same person
but that is crazy it's crazy to me is
that's the kind of evidence
that you get bill barr saying there's no
evidence we've seen to date that you
know would have changed that
outcome of the election yeah watching
someone stick a usb stick in a machine
and pull it out isn't proof that the
election was you know flipped but it is
evidence that somebody broke the law
you just can't say they changed the
results of the election he also said so
far
so we're still today yeah yeah today so
we're still waiting for the exact
information it's important not to jump
to conclusions but with these
important events it's important to pay
attention to them
and hope that it goes through the right
legal process where people could
actually get
the right information and find out more
under oath exactly what happened here
because
i mean a lot of people in the mainstream
media are saying enough let's stop
asking questions
it's already done we have the
president-elect but if we could have
four years of absolute russian collusion
madness
i think we could allow a few weeks to
ask some serious questions about our
elections which by the way
all the mainstream media pundits telling
you to trust the election results
were just telling you not to trust it
months ago especially
john oliver on his hbo show who actually
did a pretty good job
about dominion voting machines and the
entire
problem with electronic voting machines
last year
and uh now now he's denying it now
if you're questioning the elections
you're you're part of i think he said
uh a fascistic government or you're
crazy if you're questioning this this
year's elections i don't know his exact
quote so i don't want to miscode him
but he's on the complete other spectrum
where he was
a year ago providing pretty good solid
evidence pretty good
questions pretty good uh you know
evidence laid out in front of us saying
that there are some legitimate questions
that should be asked about the integrity
of our elections
i watched this video that they put out
where you can see them pulling out a box
from under a table
there's a website called lead stories
which has uh defamed me
and published fake news about me uh they
so i had a tweet about
epstein and about bill clinton being in
flight logs
and you know witness iding him and they
took that tweet called it fake news
but then wrote their their fact check
which basically confirmed everything
it's just like
it's it's a scam they say here's the
article here's the truth and they don't
care what you actually said
they just want to make sure that on
facebook people who see it it says fake
news
so they fact check this story about
giuliani
and they say it's fake news it was legal
ballot counting
nothing to see here why well they asked
someone and that someone said don't
worry everything's fine
that explains it case closed but here's
the best part
one of the quotes they have this this is
what the person says they say francis
watson chief investigator for the
georgia secretary of state
yes the gop who said that we've already
looked into it nothing to see here
told lead stories during a phone call on
december 3rd that the ballots were in
standard containers
no one's disputing that and the work
during the time in question had nothing
to do with pulling ballots from
under the table she said quote there
wasn't a bin that had balance in it
under the table so what did we see them
pull out from under the table that was a
ballot box
full of ballots and then start counting
it wasn't empty she says it was an empty
bin
and the ballots from it were actually
out on the table when the media were
still there
and then it was placed back into the box
when the media were still there and
placed next to the table
there is a video you can watch where
a woman with braids walks up to a group
of people then those people all leave
then they walk over to the table pull a
box out from under
the table four boxes they do it multiple
times
and this person who's debunking this
says it was placed next to the table
you can literally watch the video where
it's not next to the table this is not a
real fact check did giuliani actually
say it was proof
oh yeah the headline said that he said
it was proof he's saying it's the
smoking gun
he didn't say evidence he said proof he
tweeted election in georgia is now
proven to be a fraud
then he tweeted again the videotape
doesn't lie fulton county democrats
stole the election it's now beyond doubt
go to the tape
smoking gun from georgia he's destroying
his credibility by
throwing the word proof around so ha
haphazardly because that's
what i don't mind the evidence but it's
definitely not proof something it's the
hardest evidence we have so far
but there's there so there was a a
document that was going around showing
the
the vote tabulations in real time
there's been a whole bunch of
analysis around this now in one of these
uh data dumps
it was at i think like 12 34 am and this
is from the new york times
the new york times like data release on
the election night so it's december
i'm sorry november 4th 12 34 a.m around
23
900 or so ballots came in and 98 were
for joe biden
now people are seeing this video and
going back to those uh
articles and those you know analyses
saying wait a minute
on this day in georgia at 12 34 a.m we
know they stopped counting
at one am that means you've got
four ballot boxes you can see in the
video each estimated to contain 6 000
votes
24 000 votes now people are going back
to the previous data and saying
98 percent for joe biden that looks like
it's that they're tabulating those
ballot boxes they pull
from under the table so is it is it
proof is it the smoking gun
i think if you went to a regular person
and show them that video
they'd be like what if you then show
them the data from the from the from the
you know the the election counting
releases that were coming in people your
average person is probably going to be
like oh yeah
so i'm not saying it's i'm not saying
it's true i'm just saying when it comes
to these situations that are extremely
political
it's proving something beyond a
reasonable doubt for me i look at this
and i'm like how do you argue against it
what do you have to say when they're
like oh no it's next to the table no it
wasn't
it was it was normal ballot counting
then why do we have two sworn affidavits
from people saying they were told they
had to leave and counting it stopped
not only that in georgia you know how
they claimed a water main broke
and they had to stop counting never
happened what an election i'd remember
this they were like a water main broke
in georgia so they're sending everybody
home really weird we also had a story
where a guy apparently was a leaky
toilet that's it
like what does that have to do why can't
you count votes because of a leaky
toilet
there's another story where a guy said
that in georgia they told everyone they
had to leave
because counting was done they're like
no we're not leaving so they drove a
forklift and blocked the view so they
couldn't actually see what was going on
yeah it doesn't help your cause when
you're trying to block people from
seeing what you're doing
and it doesn't help your cause when you
have a record of steel stealing
elections
just like the dnc did against bernie
sanders so
uh i still no matter what have to give
the benefit of the doubt until we have
their side of the ver
their side of the story their version of
events i'm still waiting
uh until these court proceedings happen
i i i want to see more i want to see
everything and i want to hear the
counter argument to what we're seeing
right now because
i think we definitely deserve there's no
real argument right now
well they're just look look that's why i
pulled up the fact check
no when they publish a quote where it's
like they looked into it and it said it
was nothing i'm like
that's that's look i get it that's not a
response i want that lady under oath
explaining her exactly what she was
doing every little thing
uh you know described in detail because
we deserve that exactly coming out and
saying trust me
no i watched the video liars yeah yeah
they cheated bernie sanders out of the
no these are the republicans these are
the georgia republicans it's it's it's
it's raffensburger and it's brian county
i'm talking about an enlarger picture in
this whole election
what we're seeing happening here there's
definitely a lot of anomalies that don't
make sense
for sure and i think it was wrong what
happened to bernie especially in 2016
and now but
i do have to say if you won't fight for
yourself why do you expect me to fight
for you
he took it he bent over and he was like
yes support hillary after everyone knew
including his own supporters who who
were just
shocked bernie bernie sanders in 2016
the millionaires and the billionaires
in this country are exploiting the
working class and then 2020
in 2020 no no no outside of that 2020
goes the million i'm
not not the millionaires the
billionaires in this country are
supporting joe biden vote for him
when you say he got cheated out of the
election i know i've heard some stuff
about what what the dnc did
when you look at debbie wasserman
schultz and the way that she was getting
the electors during the selection you
saw the rise in numbers you saw the
there's a lot of different little tricks
that were used
uh you know during the primaries that a
lot of people directly point the finger
at the dnc head debbie wasserman schultz
which
was uh she was fired she she essentially
was
ousted as the dnc chair and hired
immediately afterwards for the hillary
clinton campaign
uh and then and again this is also the
same person that looked at me and told
me that there wasn't a deposition matrix
this position the disposition matrix i
keep messing it up uh but but but
yet again when you look at the they were
feeding questions of the media so that
hillary had advantages and debates
right they were there there are leaked
emails where they were basically talking
about how they were doing everything in
their power to help hillary clinton and
something about his jewishness right in
the leaked emails i don't know about i
don't remember i don't remember
any of that but we do we do have uh uh
some more serious information
uh uh news pertaining to georgia so this
is from just last night president
trump's attorneys asked georgia
legislature to
overturn election select own electors
and they might do it how do you think
this is going to play out this is why i
really wanted to kind of
know how and where do we go from here
well so there's some things that could
happen yeah for one
we get pennsylvania michigan and georgia
if these three states maybe arizona
maybe nevada if their legislatures which
are
which are controlled by republicans
dispute the election and won't shut up
about it
then by december we're four days out
if they don't rectify this in four days
that's it yeah i don't see those votes
those votes aren't going to count
trump's going to win i'm not saying he's
probably probably going to win i'm not
saying he's likely to
but i'm saying if the legislatures
dispute this
it doesn't matter what the governor say
because the constitution is clear
that the legislatures decide if the if
the state
legislatures issue a statement to the
the supreme court the federal government
saying
here's what we think or just send their
own slate of electors without even
coming into session
then you're going to have you know
pennsylvania has 40 electors
instead of instead of 20 and then what
which ones do we count i don't know
democrats are gonna be we gotta count to
one the joe biden one no we dispute you
gotta count the trump ones
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you